there's a new material that's been
attracting a lot of attention online
it's being called an invisibility cloak
you know as in Harry Potter's but it's
not magic that's hiding these objects
from view need for military applications
the thin bendable plastic sheets line
with a series of lenses are specially
designed to obscure objects like a
soldier or a tank we wanted to find out
more so we called up guy creamer one of
the founders of hyper stealth the
company that makes it the pinnacle of
camouflage we knew going into this was
going to be something that could not
only hide you in any environment but
also mask your movement behind whatever
it is that that ended up becoming the
solution what is it and kind of how does
it work it's off-the-shelf material the
light is being bent left and right as
you're looking through it and so what
you're actually seeing is what's behind
me on on both sides and on an angle so
the light comes out and it does this and
it creates this dead zone in the back so
that the further back I am the more
impressive the invisibility becomes can
you walk me through kind of like the
best way to use this prototype so
version one we simply put on a riot
shield and so it's it's just one piece
of the material with the flat back and
we've just affixed it to the the riot
shield there so if I hold it up and and
really impress them then the distance is
not that far away and the farther I hold
it the better it is and the closer I
Bowl that the worse it is that would be
one simple application for a tactical
team going into a bad hostage situation
that's the version two material is here
and you can see that there's a little
blurry section in the middle and I
manipulate that right now and I can get
this actually quite a bit closer to me
then I can with version one so it's
about half the distance for this to be
effective how do you envision kind of it
being used in the battlefield I believe
at some stage we will figure out
the principle of of what you're seeing
there and manipulate that material into
something that can go into a parachute
type material or a clothing type
material if it's in a parachute then a
sniper could repurpose it once he he
lands on the ground and turn it into a
sniper hide or even a poncho can
actually utilize that lens large-scale
to hide a tank or a building and still
have that thinness that we're working
with on all the other applications out
there it's still kind of like distorted
right like you said like there might be
a delay but the the target or whatever
knows that someone has come into the
room if you're using you know that riot
shield or something like that do you
think you'll ever get to the point where
like they're just totally surprised or
that humans really can't see what's
going on we're not trying to pull the
wool over people's eyes with this we're
trying to show them this is the the
reality of the prototypes and and what
we have using off-the-shelf material
given manufacturing we're gonna be able
to manipulate those areas that are
hiding the target and reduce the areas
that are causing the enlargement of the
target will we achieve full invisibility
with this I I can't say yes or no but we
can achieve something that is close
enough that it would be sufficient for
combat use out there we wanted to find
out more about the science behind this
material so we called up dr. John Howell
a physicist and specialist in quantum
optics who has studied making the
visible invisible he says this
technology is more about cloaking like
ships and Star Trek been true
invisibility you have the cloaking
device so what do you think of the
invisibility cloak first of all I think
it's fun to watch it's clever and I
think it has a lot of practical use but
its definition as a cloak here is not
it's a good way of doing optical
camouflage when I when I think of
cloaking what I mean is you see the
background undisturbed but whatever
you're trying to make it visible is in
front of that background a lot of
illusions we're basically making you
think you're looking at something that
you're not
for example your you have sunlight can
be done put it through a lens and you
look at the ground you see a comfortable
sharp focal spot in a cylindrical lens
they're long and they're skinny and
instead of coming to a point they come
to a line so if you have light goes
through a cylindrical lens it comes to a
line it goes to a focus and then it
starts to diverge a lenticular sheet is
an array of cylindrical lenses and now
what you've done is you have lights
gathering off a person you know that's
the person or the thing that you want to
hire then it's going to go towards the
observer but when it hits that
lenticular sheet it diverges you still
are going to get light from the object
you're just going to get a lot less
light from the object but it's how it's
moving that light around and if you
don't want to see something if you want
to hide something you simply just make
it so light rays that are coming from
the object are sent to different
locations you this is kind of more of an
existential question but do you think
it's really possible it sounds like
researchers have been able to do
cloaking with some wavelengths but do
you think it will ever really be
possible to do it at your wavelengths
that we can see can you get cloaking
answers yes and there's versiv way of
thinking about it so now if I take the
light ray and then I had one other
element to it which is I know the
wavelength I know
its direction and I know its position
then I can calculate where that line
will be at any future time and be able
to predict it so now let's suppose I
take a measurement over here I in turn
in a position a direction and a color
for a light ray and then I say okay
mathematically I know in at this point
you know I know it was going to be
coming this direction so I know it
against over here it should be doing
this so I can get all that information
and then send it send all the
information out at this point I've been
able
recreate that library so it really comes
down to how well can you measure it and
how well can you admit it why don't we
have an invisibility cloak now than if
it's like possible engineering is a bit
of a challenging project because now
what you're not you're not just
collecting a single read you're
collecting all rays from all directions
right right because you're not just what
you have to know so much about you could
probably make like maybe an invisibility
device like for a certain room where you
control the lights or something like
that but it would be harder to do it in
like a changing environment but it then
becomes a really challenging how do you
determine the direction position very
red how do you admit in a given
direction and position for every ray but
once you've solved that problem then you
have this ability you know the classic
is Harry Potter's I would label that as
a broadband omnidirectional invisibility
cloak and what that means is that it has
to work over the entire wavelength that
our eyes work and it has to be no matter
what direction you view it you you want
to have it so that Harry Potter is not
visible and the background remains
undisturbed that's the holy grail of
invisibility can it be done I hope so I
think would be fun to do thank you so
much for being patient with us and
answering all of our questions this is
really really fascinating good luck -
thanks
[Music]